behind me is the Carpenters arms the
notorious London pub once owned by the
Kray twins now of course it's a regular
London pub in trendy Shoreditch the
ukulele shop opposite it but that's not
what I'm here to talk about I'm here to
talk about the people in there you see I
could say that the people in there were
drunk I could say that but I'm not going
to because under English libel law that
could get me sued see English libel law
has three tests for whether something is
libelous first is it published and yes
this is on YouTube it's published
secondly is it defamatory how could it
impugn someone's character and yes
saying they're drunk to do that and
thirdly is it false except that's not
strictly the test because the burden of
proof if you are sued for libel is on
you the defendant I would have to prove
that the people in there whoever they
were were actually drunk and without a
police record or without a breathalyzer
test or footage of them downing an
entire bottle of vodka I can't actually
prove that I can say that they are happy
or perhaps merry or in a pub and that's
fine that's all true but I can't
necessarily prove that they are actually
drunk now for that the British press has
a wonderful euphemism for many years
tired and emotional coined after a
politician called George Brown I gave
that as a statement in 1967 for the
reason he was behaving erratically
taiidan emotional got picked up by
private are you the famous satirical
magazine and it entered British parlance
and now a lot of folks know that tired
and emotional means drunk which means
that nowadays journalists in training
are taught not to describe someone as
tired and emotional that just using that
phrase itself might be libelous because
everyone knows that it means drugged
British libel law is terrifying if
you're a journalist which is something
you might not have known